-Welcome back. We're here
with Martin Lawrence right here!
Now...
[ Cheering and applause ]
Martin, I want to talk
about the reunion special
-Yes.
-because what did it feel like
to have the original cast back
together after all this time?
-It felt great, man,
just to see them again
and get back together.
It felt like we was going back
to work, you know,
and only thing that was missing
was our brother Tommy Ford.
-Agh!
[ Claps ]
-But we got to honor him
in the right way.
[ Applause ]
-Aw, he was great.
I mean, is everyone still
just funny and so like
-Yes.
-you go right back to the days,
you're like, "Oh, we could do
this right now"?
-Yes, when you see the reunion,
you'll see the humor
and the laughter in the reunion,
you know.
We just pick up
where we left off.
-Yeah.
-These are some of the
characters, of course,
that you talk about.
Dragonfly Jones.
[ Laughter ]
I think
Sheneneh Jenkins,
Romey Rome, and Roscoe.
I think, still, my favorite
thing is Dragonfly Jones,
[ Laughter ]
when he -- Do you remember when
he got in a fight
in the parking lot?
[ Laughter ]
Well, I'm saying it
like it's not you.
[ Laughter ]
You, as Dragonfly,
and then you went up and you
dialed 911 on the ATM machine.
[ Laughter ]
-Right, right, right.
-You were dialing, 911.
One of the best physical comedy
things ever.
Would you ever
do the show again?
People want to know.
-I think --
[ Cheering and applause ]
Well, you know,
the "Martin" show was like
catching lightning in a bottle
and I don't think we can redo
that again, you know.
I wouldn't mind working with the
cast again on something,
but I don't think we could do
that again.
-Maybe like, instead of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe,
it's the Martin
Cinematic Universe.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Well, I would love to see
a movie with Sheneneh.
[ Cheering, yeahs, applause ]
-Yes!
-And, remember, we were supposed
to do a movie with Sheneneh
and Jamie Foxx,
with Wanda,
and that never came about.
[ Laughter ]
But if we could ever get
that together,
I think y'all would love that.
-Ooh, my God.
[ Cheering and applause ]
No, that would be --
You got to do that.
-Yeah.
-You have to do that.
Or even like I could see like
did anyone ever pitch you
like "Lil Martin" or anything?
[ Laughter ]
Like a cartoon or something
like that?
Because you got all these
great characters.
-Yeah, we got some stuff coming.
-You do? Alright.
-Yeah.
-You know we love you.
Come back whenever you want to.
-Love you, man.
-Martin Lawrence,
the one and only.
[ Cheering and applause ]
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's a peek
at "Martin: The Reunion."
Take a look at this.
-You guys felt so natural,
so cultural and it felt --
Did you know that that was
the approach you wanted
to take or...?
-We just went for it, you know.
I don't know if that's the
approach I wanted to take,
but I was in the moment.
We were in the moment
and we were just going for it.
We wanted the show to succeed
and we just did
everything we could to try
to make that happen.
-You're being a little humble.
-Yeah.
You know you humble.
Stop playing.
First of all,
he was driving the bus
and you had to keep up.
-He was funny.
You had to anticipate
his movements.
You didn't know where he was
going to go at any moment.
He was freaking brilliant!
-Yeah, that's exactly right!
[ Cheering and applause ]
Martin Lawrence, everybody!
"Martin: The Reunion"
is streaming now on BET+.